you started writing a movie recently on
Twitter is this true well so I was on a
long flight one time and I had an idea
for a film and I started tweeting the
screenplay out and the film is called
ghost plane and I thought that you know
since we're all here there's a lot of
people watching it maybe we could could
do like a table read of the script to
see if there's some investors that maybe
want to invest in this wait a minute
what am I to do it you don't want to do
a table read here on the show you guys
papers out I didn't know what they were
this is a screen alright this is you
tweeted this out and it's called ghost
plane it's called ghost plane and I'm
gonna read the stage directions and I'll
also be reading the part of the hero a
handsome Indian guy named Raj okay I
wanted to play the Indian guy but I
don't know I got a role for you don't
worry okay so here's the scene okay
interior airplane okay okay Raj is
reading an in-flight magazine looking
very handsome out of nowhere a box full
of peanut bags falls into his lap he
looks up Raj speaks holy [ __ ] there's a
ghost on this plane okay I'm just I know
there's a ghost cuz it's a ghost plane :
come on okay
do you not get the concept all right I'm
sorry believe all ghosts on a plane are
like a faulty latch
okay all right
the flight attendant played by Academy
Award winner Jennifer Lawrence puts back
at the box of nuts all right does you
I'm Jennifer Lawrence can you just read
it going okay you King nuts you stay up
there that's what it says I'm just
reading what you wrote
I mean : I get it you're not Jennifer
Lawrence but you got to try a little bit
harder I mean Mark Cuban is watching
them right thinking about whether you
should invest please all right now reads
your next line excuse me sir but aren't
you Izzy's Ansari star of the critically
acclaimed TV show Parks and Recreation
what no just got on my handsome eating
guy
I'm Aziz Ansari you're racist Jennifer
Lawrence then the nut box
falls again and the bags of nuts just
start flying at all the passengers and
like it's really scary it's like in 3d
so like not just like flying in your
face and at this point you and I see all
these bags of nuts flying around and we
look at each other and at the same time
we say then
[Applause]
the the captain played by Academy Award
winner Tom Hanks makes an announcement
everyone please stay call but there's a
ghost on board but don't worry the
cockpit is secure and the ghosts
probably can't get in here but then he's
interrupted by the co-pilot
Academy Award winner Christoph Waltz the
ghost got in here
a lady passenger screams Conan this is
you again I'm not gonna scream like a
whoop
now the planes in full-on ghost mode
like there's nuts flying around
everywhere passengers are like
levitating and stuff you know babies are
flying and hitting people Jennifer
Lawrence starts trying to make out with
Raj and I'm like Jennifer being a
professional and then a mysterious man
in a hoodie steps forward and he says if
you want to stop this ghost plane you'll
need my help he takes off his hoodie and
it's Academy Award nominee Liam Neeson's
then Liam Neeson takes out a gun and
says my name is Air Marshal Ray Parker
jr. and I ain't afraid of no ghosts
[Applause]
you